hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jeremy
tonight we're gonna watch the trailer
for get on up that's what I tell my
penis every morning or before I'm about
to have sex because it tends to fail I'm
so sorry
yeah man [ __ ] whiskey dick dude let
me tell you the last time I almost had
sex I was with this girl
we were both drinking a little bit and
then we got to do some stuff BAM I'm
naked she's naked I'm a little too drunk
can't get it up so this movie better be
one hell of an inspiring picture in a
tutorial on how to get your thing up
James Brown clearly knew how to do it
and he's black black I know [ __ ] black
people are so lucky you know I feel
sorry for the black people with small
penises or medium sized being ha I don't
know if ever bumped into a friend that
has one of those because I always assume
it's like over a footlong yeah they
probably use it like pick up things and
yeah I can see they use it it's like
that's what when I picture of a black
person's dick I think of a surefire
flashlight this long heart and just goes
it everywhere yeah dude best situation
ever
sorry James Brown I know you're not with
us good thank you mr. Brown thanks for
your black let's walk your trailer your
biopic movie hmm
oh we had a tough life growing up on
that hair oh look at that footwork oh
yeah six of that I like this already
with the shoe just got a little
emotional and know you went through
struggles Mick Jagger produces I love
his music I know you guys love me oh he
really doesn't make you I dance
dude I gotta sleep that's a really good
job in the roll act now I know it's like
he seems like he's not going to over the
top I'm not doing impersonation
like it looks like he's doing a really
good job so it's basically not about a
penis no not at all no very misleading
title very yeah I mean if you're not a
hardcore fan of music you're gonna be
very much you're walking into the wrong
movie basically yeah but it's cool I
mean I like I like those kinds of movies
where you could learn something from it
you know it just kind of picks you up
biopics never make me want to be a
celebrity there at the same time because
they're always like look how glamorous
your life was but it really sucked at
the same yeah hell of an emotional
journey yeah this is so yeah it's like
no-one's biopic journey seems to be like
feelin amazing life I know it's so he's
that for heaven he was famous but there
was like all kinds of me I'm going on
yeah you see I hadn't closed her dirty
and everything and oh yeah he has issues
his mom positive hard core issues we're
never suspected that I would I never
even thought of that
yeah I mean he's good with ladies yeah
do you see how much she was surrounded
by a knight little clip
yeah dude [ __ ] his hair in that man we
got it in the music man we got that is
the thing we got to do to constantly and
being consistent with getting girls oh
well let's maybe we just made me really
sad yeah same here
laughs near the channel you can
subscribe right here and you can
subscribe to Jeremy's channel right here
where right there yeah we're put at the
bottom down there you know
he does like personal training he does
dancing guys an amazing dancer awesome
body great ass hung like a horse
calves did not know all those details
that you've noticed about me oh yeah
I've noticed a lot Jeremy yeah yeah
especially when you're not looking say
hello it's really good I make sure to go
to the gym catch him in the locker room
it's really nice
ah the locker room yeah these I've seen
some creeper there yeah kind of like
like an eye buggy popping out yeah I
hide in the walkers it's really small
yeah you probably put your camera in
there too huh you're like yeah yeah dude
it to do when it's perfect I get great
focus on it wow there's some new shout
out see there you go okay so that's your
fun shoutouts you got to say it with
enthusiasm this is a shout out so we
know it shout wait you sound like Caesar
from Planet of the Apes that's pretty
good that movie makes me laugh as
serious as it is some parts you're just
like no original a talking ape Roman
Colin Colin he said I want to shout out
please lol so he was like freaking out
what Howard after he asked that question
yeah that's our casting now I want a
shout-out please mom
[ __ ] thinks I really want one
yeah whatever Roman fine be that way
about it be that way Roman maybe he's a
great God that that Rome end whereas not
speak regarding precious sure he knows
what a great Jeremy Jeremy oh maybe you
wrote him oh my gosh Oh can't bow so
there we go that was the oh he said can
I get a shadow sorry it's not your honor
can I get a shout-out also from Jerry
he's awesome and Ryan you're funny as
hell and Sally I love your hair and I
guys should do movie vlogs when you go
watch a movie you should do a movie
you realize everything you just said was
one second
there's not one period and Jerry awesome
while Ryan Bunny and Sally pretty and
guys do movie vlogs new movie vlogs and
there's still not a period at the end
still not a period so the sentence for
all we know is continuing yeah another
dimension that's why he's names that's
why maybe his name says Oh Campo there's
no like period so he's like when do I
stop hmm
that's what I say when I'm doing the fat
girl yeah when do I stop yeah when do
you it's more like when can I stop Oh
looks like an annoyance hmm I see I'm
just kind of like hugging like a like a
beanbag yeah hey there's more to love it
that you know got worried about like
trying to find a spot you just BAM do
you hear that Jeremy that's the sound of
people hitting the unsubscribe I just
thought about it never experienced that
I don't wanna say this without sounding
like a douche so I'm gonna try but I
have been with it with girls who are not
the thinnest person in the world that's
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with that now this isn't cracking a
little it's you know with Greg jokes I
really like you know yeah I matter of
fact that's all the kind of girls I get
I need I need hotter chicks I need you I
need you like Jared Danny
ah see I make plenty I turned those
girls into what they want to become so
it's what they oh no it's the progress
of it all I turned average-looking girls
to some people good I still think these
girls are pretty pretty yeah you know
but then they just become a whole
different beast
you're like talk about training them oh
yes oh yes yeah I was like what do you
mean you're turning them into something
else
yeah sorry Jerry is not here but he you
know he's busy and Sally's in Florida
right now so yeah we and we are gonna
start doing some movie video blogs
actually we do movie reviews now and
everything so yeah but thank you for
your support and love and consideration
of the channel Matthew holler McGill I
love comments like this shout-out please
it's like ordering that's it and I have
a water cup too well here's your shanem
Matthew holler McGill holler make you
holla at the McGill yeah all caps yeah
basically or middle to last name yeah
that your middle name should just be the
[ __ ] caps yeah he said well you said
please so yeah hope you guys like shut
up thank you guys for tuning in this has
been us watching a trailer for a movie I
already forgot what your trailer for
what was it Oh James Brown James Brown
movie get up